Sukuna is Hisoka on steroids.
Just like probably the most iconic character
in Hunter x Hunter, the king of curses is
loved for his charisma, is purely driven by
his sadistic hedonism and serves as a complete
wild card in the story, helping both the heroes
and the villains, just as often as he likes
to hurt or straight out ignore them, always
looking for a way to benefit himself.
And yet, despite his cruelty, selfishness
and darkness, just like the psychopathic clown,
the king of curses is as popular with fans
as most of the "good guys".
What exactly is it that makes Sukuna so fascinating
to watch?
As I've already mentioned in previous videos,
Akutami loves taking popular tropes from anime
and manga, merge them and improve on them.
and so, it comes as no big surprise that Sukuna
emerges as one of the most rounded, complex
and intriguing villains, I have ever come
across.
So let's discuss his background, his role
in the Story, his relationship to Itadori,
Megumi and Gojo and whether or not he truly
is all evil.
This is the story of Ryoumen Sukuna.
Sukuna is introduced in the story as the king
of curses, who lived over a thousand years
ago in the golden age of jujutsu in ancient
Japan, where he was the most powerful being
alive, despite being an actual human.
As Akutami clarified in an interview however,
he wasn't so much a cursed user as a "natural
calamity."
Apparently he still remembers his past life
as a human as well.
After his death however, he became a cursed
spirit, so powerful, that his body could not
be destroyed, but had to be divided into parts
and sealed away.
- My god.
This man akutami really has a rich imagination
to come up with something like - hm?
- aaaand I'm being told that that this is
actually based on Japanese History.
It's time for a short Japanese history lesson.
Because, as it turns out, Ryoumen Sukuna,
is actually a historic figure.
Well, kind of.
This person is mentioned in the second oldest
record of Japans history, the Nihon Shoki,
completed in the 8th century ad.
Admittedly though, parts of it cross heavily
into mythology and shinto religion, so it
is often impossible to separate legend from
fact.
In this book however, that is filled with
myths and politics alike, Sukuna is described
as a demon-like person, significantly taller
than any human with two faces, two arms and
two legs.
The epithet Ryoumen by the way, literally
meaning two-faced.
He is said to have appeared in Hida prefecture,
todays Gifu, that you can see on the map here,
see, here's Tokyo, that didn't exist back
then, that's Gifu.
I don't want you finishing this video without
having learned anything.
Anyways.
Here he terrorized the people, until a brave
military commander was able to expel him from
the land.
Interestingly enough however, while the Nihon
Shoki described him as a villain and an enemy
of the emperor, people in Hida and Mino Provinces
treated Ryomen-sukuna as a hero and benefactor
and worshipped him.
And there is actually a shrine dedicated to
Sukuna still existing in Gifu prefecture,
which a statue - that - doesn't look quite
as cool as this.
[switch between epic sukuna anime and that
statue with epic loud music and derpy quiet
music] Bless Anime.
Now, since there is still very little that
we know about him, I think the best way to
understand Sukuna's character is by looking
at his three most defining relationships so
far, that each give us a different perspective
on his personality.
These relationships are Gojo, Itadori and
Megumi, who has long been teased to play a
central role
in the story.
As you might remember from my analysis of
gojo's character, there are a lot parallels
between these two.
Being the two most self-centered and individualistic
characters in the story, both were introduced
pretty much at the same time, right at the
beginning of the story, one as the strongest
sorcerer and one as the king of curses.
And the two of them clearly share this incredible
aura of power, superiority and total control,
especially during battle.
next to their immense charisma, both of them
also value strength over all else.
In a way though, both are also incredibly
immature and cruel, playing with other people,
and especially Sukuna turning every fight
into
a game.
These parallels that akutami draws between
the two, strongly suggest, that these two
will face off again at some point in the story.
And yet, there are also some striking differences
between the two, that I think will help us
explain sukuna's character a little better.
The most fundamental difference here, is of
course that gojo is a good guy and sukuna
a baddy.
But since we are dealing with a lot of morally
grey and quite complex characters here, let's
not be that superficial.
The main moral difference between the two
lies in their approach towards the central
moral question of jujutsu Kaisen.
What constitutes a good life worth living?
For gojo, the answer here is strength itself.
When you are strong you can use that strength
to shape the world as you please, which in
gojo's case means helping those he cares for.
Sukuna's approach is quite similar.
However for him, a life worth living is the
most extreme form of hedonism, as he uses
his power to satisfy any of his desires, which
often include the mental or physical tormentation
of others.
Gojo’s self confidence, always using his
strength for the sake of others and trying
to make a better world as he sees fit are
all good things, but the fact that he believes
no matter how strong he becomes no matter
how hard he fights he’ll always die alone
because it’s not worth becoming close to
others in the Jujutsu World is the tragedy
of his character.
Whereas Sukuna in contrast either doesn’t
care or has reached a point of no return,
having become numb to the world around him
na living purely for and relying only on himself.
Same as with Hisoka however, as modern neuro
science has found, hedonism and living out
each and every one of your desires is anything
but equal to being happy or being fulfilled.
Instead, this sort of hedonistic lifestyle,
speaks for some sort of deep trauma in the
past.
Daniel Kahneman, an Israeli psychologist,
introduced the concepts of the experinencing,
vs the remembering self.
The Experiencing Self is the one that is experiencing
the emotional state in the moment, like eating
chocolate ice cream or you know tormenting
the teenager you are stuck in, while the remembering
self is the memory of the experienced moment
looking back.
Thus, while relaxing at the beach in some
resort is probably a lot more fun while you're
there, exploring the history of Rome in the
heat of summer may suck while you're there,
but makes for way richer memory when thinking
back to it.
And bringing this all the way back to sukuna,
when someone is only living purely driven
by the experiencing self, this usually means
you prefer not to engage to much with your
past and long-term consequences.
What this tells us about the sadistic king
of courses, who used to be human after all,
is that he probably had a quite tragic past,
that drove him into abandoning his humanity.
So, unlike Mahito, who Akutami described as
being evil by nature, I expect Sukuna to have
a much more complex background as to why he
became as cruel and lust-driven as he has.
That will be one hell off a backstory for
sure.
Coming back to our comparison, while Gojo
was pretty much born with ridiculous strength
and perception, and thus was used to having
the upper hand in battle, Sukuna, despite
his power, is surprisingly focused during
all his battles.
No matter if against gojo or Megumi, he is
always analyzing his opponent, trying to figure
out exactly whats going on, so he can counter
as efficiently as possible.
As he mentions, he appears to have an extremely
detailed understanding of what curses, cursed
energy and true jujutsu really are.
All of this would make a lot of sense, if
sukuna had to struggle his way to the top
from basically rock-bottom.
One last important parallel between Gojo and
Sukuna, in contrast to their individualism
is their approach to others.
While they both prefer to rely on their own
power, they both long to understand those
around them, even if for different reasons.
Sukuna’s one redeeming feature for now,
is that when people are strong he will acknowledge
them and actually finds them interesting,
as we can see with Megumi.
But bottom line is, Sukuna is so focused on
strength, to try and fill the emptiness inside
him, by satisfying his every desire.
Funnily enough, he shares that trait not only
with Gojo, but also with the main character,
Itadori Yuji.
He is the third person, who also thinks that
power will help him live a good life by trying
to save as many people as possible.
And in regards to their relationship, Sukuna
not only bares similarities to Hisoka, but
also unites elements from stories like Naruto,
Bleach or Attack on Titan: The trope of the
vessel.
Just like Naruto and Eren, Itadori Yuji also
serves as the container for a source of immeasurable,
destructive power, that allow them to play
way above their league.
However, while the titan powers lack any personality
in themselves, and Kuruma turns out to be
a lonely, misunderstood and used creature,
that doesn't want to get involved with Naruto
or his life, Sukuna is an actual evil person,
that constantly talks to Itadori and actively
tries to harm him.
In that sense, I think that the closest comparison
that we can draw is with bleach, and by that
I mean the good part of Bleach, and that is
with Hichigo, Ichigo's dark self.
An aspect of the self that is presented as
an antagonist.
Have you ever wondered, why Sukuna looks so
much like Yuji?
We never see the face he originally had, he
always specifically takes Itadori’s form.
As we know, while the part of sukuna inside
Itadori would die, if he were to die, the
parts of his soul in the remaining fingers
would survive.
So this Sukuna we have met, in a unique way
seems to be tied to Itadori.
Whenever Itadori can't control his darkest
emotions like fear or anger, he starts to
loose control over Sukuna, in other words
giving in to his own hedonistic instincts.
For example, once Itadori consciously acknowledges
his anger towards Todo, he’s able to deal
with it in a more healthy way.
And so, just like Ichigo had to take control
over his shadow self to use his powers, similarly
it will be necessary for Itadori to take control
over sukuna, who only acknowledges strength,
In order to actually profit form his powers
and keep him from hurting others and especially
himself.
Because the only person Sukuna is actually
fixated on, is not Itadori, whom he simply
finds irritating, but Megumi Fushiguro.
What a transition.
Fushiguro in himself is such a fantastic character,
that he deserves a video of his own, which
will be the next one after this.
Luckily, Sukuna is not exactly interested
in Fushiguro for his personality, but for
his abilities.
The connection between the two has been hinted
at since their encounter during the cursed
womb arc.
And just to get it out of the way: of course
Sukuna wants to use Fushiguro for his own
purposes.
Either to regain his own body or to take on
gojo, once he has.
These statements were triggers for both Megumi
and the audience alike, but for different
reasons.
Sukuna’s words show that he has an interest
in Megumi and his ability while giving the
audience a more in-depth idea of Sukuna’s
tauntful personality . At the same time they
actually help Fushiguro to grow, something
Sukuna keeps encouraging.
In this moment Megumi prepares to use what
Gojo calls his “Trump Card” an attack
that is unconfirmed in nature, but seemingly
is the end all be all for Megumi.
And funnily enough, both him and Gojo have
much more faith in his abilities than he himself
seems to.
Whatever he sees in Megumi, it seems to make
it worth reviving Itadori and staying in his
body, something he's not exactly enjoying.
Yuji being a one in a million potential vessel
was a breaking point for Sukuna to once again
feel human flesh but we know he doesn’t
want to stay in Yuji’s body permanently,
why not?
After all, Yuji can control his possession
and can become stronger as he absorbs more
fingers.
And should he die, the fingers within him
would actually die, unlike with curses where
the fingers would just appear where the curse
once was as they cannot be destroyed by normal
means.
And so it will be truly fascinating to see
how Sukuna's plan with Fushiguro will play
out, whether Itadori will be able to get his
respect and if we will ever get a true battle